if they get control of Congress they  will spend the next two years  investigating  President Biden and their political  opponents that's all they want to do  they see it as payback  and some some of them said that they  they're they've already got prepared  that they're going to impeach you uh by  they're not sure what for  but apparently that's beside the point  and you're laughing except they've  actually said that  they had literally said we're not sure  what the theory is but we're going to  come up with one  in fact there's an incredible clip from  I believe it was a New Hampshire debate  which I played for you where they were  going around saying what would you  impeach Joe Biden for and everybody  agreed they should impeach Biden other  than one candidate but they disagreed as  to why they should impeach him and they  have absolutely no idea in reality